so details are starting to trickle out
about the human cost of the covid era
disaster tragedy our own cultural
revolution we suppose most of our time
talking about the big things but
Underneath It All were millions of
people suffering some in grotesque ways
here's one example at Georgetown law
school administrators demanded that
students wear masks at all time no one
was allowed to drink water in class
students of course had to take the shots
whether they wanted or not and then the
booster so one top student at the law
school called William spruance
questioned those policies on the grounds
they didn't seem rational or
scientifically Justified
administrators did not respond to his
arguments and said they suspended him
they then forced him to undergo a
psychiatric evaluation and threaten to
report him to the bar to prevent him
from becoming a lawyer he made it out
William Spruce is now practicing
attorney he's written an amazing piece
for the Brownstone Institute called
madness and law schools he joins us
tonight Williams thank you so much for
coming on it they forced you to undergo
a psychiatric evaluation
thank you for having me tonight Tucker
yes so after I was encouraged to give a
speech to a student council type group
at Georgetown
I received an email that I was
indefinitely suspended from the school
that I'd have to undergo psychiatric
evaluation and waive my right to Medical
confidentiality during the psychiatric
evaluation it would start with kind of
innocuous questions like do you ever
ever get angry followed by do you get
angry about masks and then do masks make
you want to hurt anybody so it was an
ongoing cycle of questions that were
designed to make me seem
unhinged for Willing for being willing
to question their covet policies
so we took a look actually at the speech
that you gave and and people can find it
online they can also find your piece and
I hope they will it was entirely
rational you were asking questions about
the science you turned out to be
completely right were any administrators
at the Georgetown Law Center willing to
entertain a rational conversation with
you
I found that individual professors were
willing to have the conversation with me
behind closed doors but they wish to
remain remain anonymous as for the
administrators there was no such luck
while ostensibly this was about covid it
was really part of a much larger
cycle of the events at Georgetown law we
had people like Sandra Sellers and Ilya
Shapiro who were thrown out of the
institution just for being willing to
question campus orthodoxies and it was
part of an ongoing double standard where
if you're Progressive and you
regurgitate the proper slogans then
there's an Indemnity built into shouting
down speakers this was on full display
at Stanford a few years ago a few weeks
ago rather but if you're willing to
question the Orthodoxy of Campus then
they'll bring the whole horde of
Administrators against you and work to
professionally and socially
reputationally destroy you and that's
how I saw my issue which happened in
August and September of 2020 to 2021
just four months later Ilya Shapiro was
kicked off of Campus for questioning
President Biden's decision to limit his
Supreme Court nominations to just black
women
so you went to prestigious undergraduate
college you get into one of the best law
schools in the country
how shaken was your faith in our legal
education system by this
well I thought I was attending a trade
school for a skeptical profession
I think in the long run it's hard to be
optimistic about the future judges and
administrators and unimpressive
bureaucrats because Georgetown laws
really just an incubator for an
unimpressive ruling class of tomorrow
and so these people won't stay on campus
and just make the people they're
miserable they'll be running
institutions like Georgetown law they
will be at various government agencies
they'll be judges and that to me is the
more alarming aspect I made it out of
this process
relatively unharmed I mean it was about
a week that was difficult in my life but
going forward the people have come out
to me since my piece was released about
similar stories and they're gone through
far worse than me and at the root of
this is the administrators and that's
where these students and these
professors and these ministers will go
on to inflict more damage which is why I
wrote for The Brownstone Institute which
is hoping to curb this
tied as soon as possible
what's most amazing is you're one of the
only graduates of an elite law school
brave enough to describe what you saw
there and that itself is such an
indictment really I think of your
classmates and the people who run it and
so we're especially grateful you're
willing to do this William spruance
thank you very much
thank you for having me on Tucker
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight